[Música]
la sociedad crea moldes
como hay que ser como somos
clasifique monos
eres la rubia de clase o la gordita
o el cachas
o el bizco
o el listo
también puede ser el cojo el ciego el
discapacitado
nuestro cerebro es una máquina de
clasificar y de generalizar para poder
sacar conclusiones con poca información
y eso nos ha permitido evolucionar hasta
ahora
pero y si esas generalizaciones y
presunciones estuvieran dando lugar a
conclusiones falsas
tiremos por tierra los prejuicios sobre
la discapacidad
si prejuzga vas vas a tener que
replanteárselo
y esque
el legado
el modelo de lo que entendemos por
discapacidad
ya no se sostiene
venía aquí preparando una introducción
pero la verdad que llegar aquí al
círculo este que hay la bomba fijo
intimida y me queda en blanco bueno en
cualquier caso
he venido reflexionando una cosa y es
que las charlas ted me hacen pensar que
el ser humano es extraordinario
sabéis que en el mundo hay más de 7 mil
millones de habitantes
cuántas personas con discapacidad crees
que hay un millón 10 millones 100
millones más de mil millones de personas
tienen alguna discapacidad y estos son
datos de la organización mundial de la
salud
más de mil millones de personas tienen
alguna discapacidad
pues este número se ha duplicado en 25
años
y esto ya os lo digo yo no parece
sostenible
que 1 de cada 7 personas en el mundo
tiene alguna discapacidad
vosotros los veis
yo no los veo y eso que ahora trato de
fijarme
uno de cada siete personas
lo primero que se nos viene a la cabeza
cuando hablamos de discapacidad
es esto personas en silla de ruedas pues
me ha sorprendido encontrarme que se
estima que hay 1 de cada 100 personas en
silla de ruedas pero sobre todo me hizo
reflexionar lo que un artículo decía
solo vemos 1 de cada 500
solo vemos la quinta parte de lo que hay
primero ese es un 1% está lejísimos del
1 de cada 7 personas más en 15%
pero segundo parece que las personas con
discapacidad no se las ve aunque sean
tantísimas
así que he seguido investigando
discapacidad auditiva 360 millones de
personas en todo el mundo
es como la población de los seis
países más poblados de la unión europea
alemania reino unido francia e italia
españa y polonia
imaginaste
todos sordos
discapacidad visual 300 millones de
personas en todo el mundo
ahora cojamos al resto de la comunidad
europea y a rusia
todos ciegos
esto explica dos tercios de los
discapacitados pero además me ha hecho
darme cuenta de que hay discapacidades
que a simple vista no se ven
si viene un ciego se le identifica
fácilmente porque lleva unas gafas
oscuras un bastón a un sordo no tiene
por qué notarse de nada a simple vista
ahora qué son los audífonos
microscópicos más aún
así que mi reflexión es la mayoría de
las discapacidades no se ven
así que seguí investigando
bueno pues he descubierto que hay muchas
discapacidades que son invisibles y que
no tienen por qué ser exactamente
sensoriales como las visuales o las
auditivas las cognitivas
las llamadas discapacidad intelectual
son un ejemplo pero hay otras que aún
siendo cerebrales no afectan a la
capacidad de razonamiento
en concreto muchas de las que vienen por
daño cerebral como puede ser un ictus
un ictus es la falta de riesgo sanguíneo
de una zona del cerebro se provocan
normalmente por una rotura u obstrucción
de una arteria cerebral
un ictus provoca la muerte en un 40% de
los casos
es la principal causa de muerte en
mujeres y la segunda nombres
ahora sé qué es lo que llamamos muerte
natural en ancianos
pero es que hay un 60% que sobrevive
el impacto en este 60 por ciento
generalmente no es apreciable desde
fuera
hay efectos de memoria en el habla
movilidad
sabéis qué
el número de casos de ictus también se
ha duplicado en los últimos 25 años pero
lo más curioso es que se ha multiplicado
en personas jóvenes que sobreviven
estas personas que eran con secuelas con
discapacidades que no se ven
qué está pasando
pues no lo sabemos no sabemos
exactamente pero lo que sí nos podemos
imaginar es el impacto que está teniendo
en la sociedad que va a tener en la
sociedad estamos rodeados de personas
que tienen más difícil desenvolverse
personas con dificultades de las que no
somos conscientes
conocéis a alguien que tenga alguna de
estas discapacidades invisibles
quizás pensáis y sí que os dais cuenta
de que conocéis a alguien que ha sido
víctima de un ictus
y quizás a lo mejor sabéis hasta algunas
dificultades han contado que ahora
tengan os voy a poner algunos ejemplos
de daño cerebral resultado de tanto
ictus como accidentes de tráfico
etcétera y no se ven
alguien sabe lo que es en mi pared ya
las personas con hemiparesia tienen
mermada la sensibilidad y el control en
exactamente la mitad del cuerpo
si tuvieras hemiparesia derecha y si
fueras diestro se te podría notar mucho
o muy poquito y no hacer cosas básicas
como un cubierto para comer
escribir caminar con normalidad o algo
tan simple como guardarte algo en el
bolsillo
y ojo puede que no se te note nada
y la visión en túnel sabéis de esas
mientras una persona con visión normal
tiene un campo visual de 180 grados
alguien con visión el túnel ve solo como
si estuviese mirando a través de un tubo
y la mía no pcia
esta es increíble yo no sabía que
existía algo así
en lugar de ver 180 grados que es lo que
se ve habitualmente se ven 90 grados
pero no son los de enfrente sino los de
la derecha o la izquierda pero desde el
mismo centro
sólo ve una persona con de mianos ya la
mitad de un lado desde el mismo centro a
alguien con emi anop sea derecha no
puede leer porque ve las letras de la
izquierda pero no las de la derecha las
que vienen en la mayoría de los países
cuando leemos
es normal que la memoria se vea afectada
tampoco se notará conocéis la película
memento
el protagonista olvida todo lo que
sucede a su alrededor y lo que está
haciendo en pocos segundos y algo muy
similar le pasa a drew barrymore en 50
primeras citas lucy olvida todo lo que
ha pasado durante el día adiós ea dormir
pues casos así existen
una persona con daño cerebral puede
olvidar tu nombre unos segundos después
de que se lo hayas dicho aunque
probablemente recordara otros detalles
de la conversación o no
más ejemplos hay casos de gente que
aunque sigue viendo igual que antes de
un accidente cerebral después no sabe de
qué color son las cosas no las puede
nombrar
hay personas que huelen los colores
hay gente que al hablar cree que está
hablando bien pero en realidad dice
palabras inconexas sin sentido
a la mayoría de estas personas no les
notarás nada a simple vista
hola mi nombre es maría josé y tengo un
ictus y tengo el 40%
mi nombre es pedro pablo me dio un ictus
y
espero pronto recuperarme y volver a las
canchas y poder jugar fútbol otra vez
buenos días mi nombre es rosa tengo el
50% de discapacidad
buenos días yo soy fit tengo 33 por
ciento de discapacidad tuvo derrame
cerebral hace 5 años
hola mi nombre es ana y tengo un 35% de
discapacidad
hola mi nombre es luz tengo un 58 por
ciento de discapacidad y gran invalidez
y veo el túnel y bueno mi cabeza es una
lavadora continuamente
hola soy alicia y todo un accidente de
moto después del cual tuve que dejar de
trabajar como ingeniera de
telecomunicaciones porque me cuesta
mucho concentrarme planificar
en las tareas que quiero realizar y
sobre todo iniciarlas
hola yo soy tu vives y tengo afasias es
decir que no puedo las palabras no puedo
escribir fatal y leer hay ahí que fatal
hola me llamo lourdes tuve hace tres
años una hemorragia por una caída de una
bici y ayer por ejemplo al volver a casa
me confundí y cogí la dirección
contraria y algunas veces pasó de largo
porque tengo muchos errores
hola mi nombre es evelyn tengo un grado
de discapacidad del 42% y tuve una
meningitis
hola soy laura me dio un ictus hace un
año estoy pendiente de la valoración de
discapacidad y bueno me cuesta mucho
concentrarme tengo todos los sentidos
muy agudizados y no controlo muy bien el
tiempo
hola que tal buenos días soy jose
enrique tuvo un ictus y tengo paralizado
el brazo derecho
soy luis fernando robledano y en el 2017
el 21 de marzo sufrió un ictus que me
dejó con una discapacidad del 66 por
ciento sólo veo el 50 por ciento
izquierdo de lo que era mi anterior
campo visual
tengo mentor me da la mitad del cuerpo y
tras unas pruebas un neuropsicólogo del
centro de daño cerebral me dijo y abro
comillas de acuerdo a los resultados de
los test no debería ser capaz de
mantener una conversación
porque al acabar una frase deberías
haber olvidado como las comenzado
y aquí estoy dando una charla
usando trucos que a veces fallan
pero dando una charla
teniendo lo más difícil como todos mis
compañeros
hemos estado aquí todos dando una charla
y estamos rodeados de personas que
tienen más difícil desenvolverse en la
sociedad personas con dificultades de
las que no somos ni siquiera conscientes
recordar a todas estas personas
les es más difícil a todas estas
personas desenvolverse el día a día
como vamos a integrar a personas que ya
parecen estar integradas bueno pues
primero dando a conocer lo que hemos
reflexionado hoy
hablas de las discapacidades como lo que
son dificultades no impedimentos nunca
impedimentos
hablar es lo mejor que se puede hacer
para luchar contra tabúes
segundo estemos abiertos tened en cuenta
con alguien con daño cerebral u otras
otras dificultades puede hablar raro o
lento o moverse extrañamente
pero curiosamente es su inteligencia su
cociente intelectual rara vez se ve
afectado
tercero
chicos si tienes discapacidad no lo
ocultes puede que tengas discapacidad no
eres un discapacitado de hecho para mí
tenéis superpoderes
siendo más difícil cada día lo empiezas
y lo acabas como cualquier otro
tenéis una fuerza especial no lo contéis
y a todos
estemos abiertos integrémonos no a pesar
de que algunos somos distintos algunos
son algunos sois distintos sino
hagámoslo porque todos somos iguales en
que todos somos distintos la doctora
chan ex directora de la organización
mundial de la salud dijo casi todos
nosotros tenemos o tendremos una
discapacidad temporada permanente a lo
largo de nuestra vida
así que ahora me gustaría concluir como
empecé os podéis levantar por favor a
todos aquellos que conozcáis a gente con
discapacidad y que no se les note y
ahora repetir conmigo como empecé el ser
humano es extraordinario
[Aplausos]